elles ont été utilisées pour expliquer
comment un raz-de-marée de 9 mètres apporté par l'ouragan Katrina
aurait pu inonder des communautés comme la mienne au Sud de la Louisiane
ainsi que des communautés de l'autre côté du Mississippi et de la côte de l'Alabama.
Les terres que nous perdons sont notre rempart contre la mer.
Je me suis portée volontaire pour présenter les graphiques affichés
et ma vie a soudainement changé pour la deuxième fois en deux ans.
Le graphique montrait d'immense pertes de terres dans le Sud de la Louisiane
et la mer gagnant toujours plus de terrain
Mais surtout, le graphique montrait la disparition de ma communauté
et de beaucoup d'autres avant 2050.
Je n'étais pas seule devant cette salle.
J'étais avec d'autres membres des communautés du sud de la Louisiane :
noirs, amérindiens, pauvres.
Nous croyons que nous étions unis par la catastrophe récente
mais nous avons compris que nous étions désormais unis par la mission impossible
de s'assurer que nos villes ne seraient pas englouties par la montée des eaux
causée par le changement climatique.
Amis, voisins, famille, ma ville,
je croyais qu'ils seraient toujours là.
La terre, les arbres, les marais et bayous
je croyais qu'ils seraient là comme ils l'ont été pendant des milliers d'années.
J'avais tort.
Pour comprendre ce qui arrivait à ma communauté,
j'ai dû parler à d'autres communautés autour du monde.
J'ai commencé en Louisiane du Sud avec la Nation Unie Houma.
J'ai parlé à des défenseurs de la jeunesse à Shishmaref en Alaska,
à des femmes pêcheurs sur les côtes du Vietnam,
à des défenseurs de la justice aux Fidji,
aux nouvelles générations de dirigeants
des civilisations anciennes du Détroit de Torrès.
Des communautés, présentes depuis des milliers d'années,
subissaient le même sort
et toutes se demandaient comment survivre aux cinquante prochaines années.
D'ici la fin du siècle,
plus de 180 millions de personnes
seront déplacées à cause du changement climatique,
et dans le sud de la Louisiane,
ceux qui en ont les moyens partent déjà.
Ils partent parce que la Louisiane du Sud perd du terrain
à un taux les plus rapides au monde.
La disparition est le point commun entre ma communauté du bayou
et les autres communautés côtières.
L'effacement. Voici ce contre quoi les communautés du monde se battent
car les conséquences du changement climatique commencent à se faire sentir.
J'ai passé 14 ans à défendre ces sociétés
déjà touchées par la crise du climat.
Elles se battent contre la discrimination
qui a lieu lors du relèvement après une catastrophe naturelle
et elles essaient de compenser les déplacements de populations
et l'arrivée d'autres personnes
qui voient l'opportunité de recommencer à zéro.
Depuis 2005, on appelle « réfugiés »
ceux qui partent ou sont déplacés à cause de la crise du climat,
même quand ils ne franchissent aucune frontière internationale.
Ce terme, mal utilisé,
qui devrait définir quelqu'un d'autre :
la victime,
la personne qui ne devrait pas être là,
ce terme est une barrière
à la récupération économique,
à l'intégration sociale
et à la guérison nécessaire après la crise et les traumatismes climatiques.
Les mots sont importants.
La façon dont on traite ceux qui passent des frontières est aussi importante.
Nous devons faire attention à comment ceux qui passent des frontières aujourd'hui
pour chercher refuge et sécurité sont traités
pour la simple raison que ça pourrait être vous ou un proche
qui aura besoin d'user de son droit humain à la migration
dans un futur proche.
Nous devons nous préparer pour une migration mondiale aujourd'hui.
C'est une réalité désormais.
Nos villes et nos communautés ne sont pas prêtes.
En fait, notre système économique et social
est simplement prêt à faire du profit sur le dos de ceux qui migrent.
Cela entraînera des périodes de gentrification climatique,
et ça pénalisera aussi les mouvements de population
souvent à travers le travail forcé
et souvent de façon illégale.
La gentrification climatique anticipant la montée des eaux
est visible dans des endroits comme Miami
où des communautés qui n'avaient pas accès au bord de mer
sont financièrement chassées des terrains élevés
où ils avaient été placés au départ
car les gens s'éloignent des côtes.
Ces gens sont déplacés, forcés de partir loin
du système économique et social nécessaire à leur survie.
La gentrification climatique se produit aussi après une catastrophe naturelle.
Quand beaucoup de gens quittent un endroit
pour une période de temps indéterminée,
d'autres arrivent.
On constate aussi la gentrification climatique
quand des bâtiments abîmés sont rénovés « écologiquement »
mais sont maintenant plus chers
et souvent trop chers pour la population noire, hispanique ou pauvre
qui veut rentrer chez elle.
La différence de loyer ou le fait de posséder une maison
est la différence entre pouvoir user votre droit,
votre droit humain de rentrer chez soi dans sa communauté
ou de devoir de s'installer autre part
moins adapté au climat,
moins cher
et seul.
La crise du climat, c'est bien plus
que simplement réduire nos émissions de CO2
et le débat n'est pas seulement autour des conditions météo extrêmes.
Nous sommes face à un basculement de notre réalité dans tous ses aspects.
Et la migration climatique en est une infime partie
mais elle aura un effet ricochet
sur les villes côtières et à l'intérieur des terres.
Que devons-nous faire ?
J'ai quelques idées.
(Rires)
D'abord nous devons repenser le problème.
Le changement climatique n'est pas le problème.
Le changement climatique est le symptôme le plus horrible
d'un système économique,
construit pour une minorité
afin d'extraire tout ce qu'il y a de précieux de cette planète et ses habitants
que ce soit nos ressources naturelles
ou le fruit du travail humain.
Ce système a créé cette crise.
(Applaudissements)
Nous devons trouver le courage d'admettre que nous avons trop pris.
Nous ne pouvons pas ignorer
que le monde entier paie le prix
des privilèges et du confort de seulement quelques personnes sur cette planète.
Il est temps pour nous de changer au niveau sociétal
un système qui encourage la consommation
jusqu'à atteindre un déséquilibre mondial.
Notre système social, politique et économique d'extraction
doit se transformer en un système qui régénère la terre
et fait avancer la liberté humaine autour du monde.
C'est de l'arrogance de penser que la technologie nous sauvera.
C'est de l'égoïsme de penser que nous pouvons continuer
cette approche injuste et d'extraction de la vie sur cette planète
et survivre.
(Applaudissements)
Pour survivre à la prochaine phase de notre existence humaine,
nous devons repenser notre système social et économique
pour développer une résilience collective.
La reconstruction sociale doit être axée autour de la restauration et la réparation
de la Terre
et autour des communautés qui en furent retirées,
criminalisées
et prises pour cibles pendant des générations.
Voici le plus important.
C'est par là que nous devons commencer.
Nous devons établir une nouvelle attitude sociale
qui voit l'immigration comme un point positif,
une nécessité pour la survie mondiale
et non une menace pour nos privilèges individuels.
La résistance collective signifie fonder des villes capables d'accueillir les gens
et de fournir logements,
nourriture, eau, couverture médicale
et être libéré de contrôles excessifs
et ce pour tout le monde,
peu importe qui ils sont
et d'où ils viennent.
Que se passerait-il si on commençait déjà à planifier la migration climatique ?
Les villes étalées ou en déclin pourraient utiliser cette opportunité
pour reconstruire une infrastructure sociale basée sur la justice et l'équité.
Nous pourrions donner de l'argent aux hôpitaux publics
et les aider à se préparer
face à la migration climatique,
et aux traumatismes du sentiment de perte et d'exil.
Nous pouvons donner plus de notre temps à la justice,
mais pas pour des bénéfices temporaires,
ni pour compenser des déficits budgétaires
Cela doit créer des changements sur la durée
et contribuer à faire progresser la justice.
Un tel changement est déjà possible.
Après l'ouragan Katrina,
des universités et lycées aux États-Unis ont accueilli des élèves
pour les aider à finir le semestre ou l'année sans hésiter.
Ces étudiants sont maintenant des atouts performants pour notre communauté,
et c'est à ça que nos communautés, nos entreprises et institutions
devraient se préparer désormais.
C'est le moment.
Ainsi en repensant le problème de façon plus honnête
et en restructurant nos systèmes sociaux de façon plus juste,
tout ce qu'il nous reste à faire, c'est de nous « réindigéniser »
et de faire appel à un pouvoir ancien.
Ceci signifie forcément que nous devons apprendre à suivre
- et non à en faire des symboles, ou des clichés exotiques, ni à les ignorer -
le commandement et les connaissances traditionnelles
spécifiques aux régions.
Ça signifie que nous devons nous faire des critères d'équité écologique,
de justice climatique et de droits de l'homme
la base, le socle,
le point de départ,
de la direction que notre nouvelle société doit prendre.
Tout ceci exige que nous admettions qu'il existe un pouvoir plus grand que nous
et une vie plus longue que celle que nous allons vivre.
Ça exige que nous croyions à des choses, même si nos privilèges
font que nous ne les voyons pas.
Nous devons rendre hommage aux droits de la nature.
Nous devons faire progresser les droits humains pour tous.
Nous devons transformer notre société à usage unique
et individuelle
en une société qui voit le collectif, l'humanité sur le long terme,
car sinon nous ne survivrons pas.
Nous devons comprendre que même les meilleurs d'entre nous
sont prisonniers d'un système injuste,
et nous devons admettre
que la seule façon pour vous de survivre
est que nous trouvions une solution
pour atteindre une libération commune ensemble.
La bonne nouvelle est que
nous sommes issus d'un peuple puissant.
Nous descendons de ceux qui ont, d'une façon ou d'une autre,
survécu jusqu'à que nous soyons en vie ici et aujourd'hui.
C'est une raison suffisante pour nous battre.
Et croyez votre amie de Louisiane du Sud,
les combats les plus durs sont ceux qu'il faut fêter.
Choisissons de rendre la prochaine phase de notre existence sur Terre belle,
et tant qu'on y est,
rendons-là aussi juste et équitable pour tous.
Nous pouvons le faire.
Nous pouvons le faire,
car c'est notre devoir.
C'est notre devoir car sinon nous perdrons notre planète
et nous nous perdrons nous-mêmes.
Notre mission commence ici.
Notre mission commence ensemble.
Voici ce que je vous offre.
Merci à vous de l'accepter. Merci.
(Applaudissements)